ce premier ministre la pole est à
monsieur jean charles taugourdeau
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
premier ministre 81 jours nous séparent
du résultat de l'élection présidentielle
il ne leur reste que très peu de temps à
la tête de votre gouvernement
mais suffisamment pour dresser le triste
bilan des méfaits de ce quinquennat le
président de la république l'a déjà fait
me direz vous puisque il a décidé de ne
pas se représenter
quel talent visionnaire pour lui même
mais malheureusement quel manque de
vision pour la france depuis cinq ans
vous pourrez toujours argumenter au soir
du 7 mai vous serez comptable de toutes
les conséquences des mesures que vous
aurez prises ou que vous n'aurez pas
prises durant ce quinquennat
ce ne sera plus à cause de nous comme
vous n'avez cessé de le dire pendant
cinq ans j'ai bien observé comment a
fonctionné votre majorité à géométrie
variable en fonction de vos intérêts
votre méthode est simple vous ne faites
pas vous des fêtes vous ne construisez
pas vous détruisez vun adapté pas vous
déguisez vous ne libérez pas vous
conduisez à plus de dépendances
un maître mot en quelque sorte le
nivellement par le bas sans hauteur de
vue nos enfants des difficultés en
français et bien vous réduisez le temps
d'apprentissage de notre langue
les écoliers ont des difficultés examen
vous supprimez les notes et le
redoublement les entrepreneurs les
agriculteurs les artisans les
commerçants les professions libérales se
plaignent de la paperasse administrative
vous les emprisonner avec le cic houle
compte pénibilité les familles de classe
moyenne sont en difficulté financière
vous supprimez l'universalité des
allocations familiales
les masques sont tombés votre objectif
était clair faire du clientélisme et met
les français en colère par calcul
politique pour garder le pouvoir
finalement avant de nous quitter une
seule question s'impose monsieur le
premier ministre
aimez vous vraiment la france
la parole est à monsieur michel sapin
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le président merci à ces seuls
les députés
monsieur le député quel contraste
quel contraste entre la dignité et
l'émotion de l'intervention du premier
ministre et les mots que vous avez
prononcé
quelle peine pour vous quelle peine pour
vous de ne pouvoir parler de la france
qu'avec ces termes là quand le premier
ministre n'a parlé avec les thermes à
lui monsieur le député soyons brefs et
simple dans tout exercice de la
responsabilité
il ya des choses que l'on réussit et
d'autres que l'on réussit moins bien ou
que l'on rate ce fut vrai pour vous
comme ça peut être le cas pour nous mais
il peut y avoir des résumés assez simple
de l'action de ce que vous appelez le
bilan des uns et des autres voulez-vous
que nous regardions ce qu'il est convenu
d'appeler le pipe ou font l'activité
économique de la france en 2012
c'était plus faible qu'en 2007 en 2017
ça aurait pu être plus c'est une
augmentation de 4% voulez-vous que nous
regardions le déficit commercial de la
france c'est à dire au fond la capacité
des entreprises à se battre sur le champ
mondiale là où vous aviez creuser le
déficit commercial de plus de 32
milliards
nous l'avons rétabli de plus de 25
32 milliards en moins 25 milliards en
plus la comparaison est simple net
elle est catégorique pour vous et pour
tout ce que vous avez soutenu voulez
vous que nous parlions de ce qu'il est
convenu dans un jargon un peu difficile
parfois à comprendre le taux de marge
des entreprises non vous savez très bien
de quoi je parle vous intéresser
beaucoup d'entreprises la capacité des
entreprises à créer des emplois ou la
capacité des entreprises à investir là
où vous l'aviez dégradé de plus de 3
points
nous avons réussi alors établir de trois
points dès que nous avons effacé les
effets de votre politique
pendant cinq ans voilà les faits tels
qu'ils sont alors parlons des faits au
lieu de prononcer des mots durs qui sont
démolis inutile et soyez à la hauteur du
premier ministre que vous posez des
questions
merci monsieur